é quando eu nasci eu pelo menos imagino
que eu sair um pouquinho daquela daquele
lugar escuro leque lugar é meio sombrio
imagino minha cabeça e diante de um tapa
de ante um grito que o que todo mundo
todos nós damos-lhe quando nascemos
eu comecei a perceber por isso eu vi que
tudo pra mim era colorido assim e tudo
de uma forma tudo tinha um formato
imagino que todos nós passamos por isso
a primeira coisa que a gente vê quando
ele nasce são cores e essas cores ficou
na minha cabeça durante vários tempos da
minha vida sinto velho período da minha
adolescência da minha infância quer
dizer é diante disso eu pude perceber
que o céu ele era azul realmente era
bonito lindo
só que aos seis anos de idade eu percebi
que existiam também cores tristes cores
que traziam emoções sentimentos ruins eu
perdi a minha mãe
aos seis anos de idade e perder a minha
mãe aos seis anos de idade foi um
momento muito complicado para mim porque
é você perder o porto seguro é você
perder aquela referência e você perder
aquela pessoa que na escola é quando tem
reuniões chama de reuniões chamava andré
pelas regiões de mãe nem tão ruim que ia
lá pra saber de você com você estava se
você tava conseguindo realmente é tirar
boas notas é você parar pra pensar que
os seus amigos do seu resultado não
tinha mãe eu não tinha mãe pra dar um
presente do dia das mães
então isso mexeu muito comigo e mexeu
muito comigo também porque eu vim de uma
família que não tinha uma estrutura
muito boa é a estrutura mesmo de base
familiar
a família tem uma família grande a
junção de estar junto de todo mundo
buscar é passar o domingo é junto com um
grande almoço eu tive isso na minha
infância
até mesmo porque o meu pai e ele veio de
uma educação ou de um processo
educacional muito rigoroso e ele tinha
até um apelido interessante
é que hoje eu brincando de aprender ele
trabalhava em uma grande empresa que
itabira onde que as pessoas chamavam ele
de bolão engraçada burrão aí tá bom é um
pequenino love assistida do burrão é que
eu acho assim a ponto no país no
primeiro painel burrão logo pensava que
era porque era burro mas não era isso
não era ele tinha até muito conhecimento
da área deles chegou a ser encarregado é
cuidando de várias pessoas só que ele só
tinha uma única forma de ver as coisas
eu só tinha visto uma visão se o lado
estava o quinto pela esquerda e só podia
ficar na esquerda ele não aceitava que
ninguém acrescentasse em um outro valor
ou nenhuma outra informação na vida dele
e com isso eu nunca ouvi do meu pai eu
te amo
isso é uma coisa assim que me incomodava
muito porque o povo vivia com várias
pessoas ia para casa dos amigos e ouvir
os pais falam eu te amo meu filho não é
um não tive isso ela é da minha da minha
adolescência com isso tudo eu fui criado
num lugar aqui em itabira onde que a
minha de à minha esquerda é da minha
casa tinha maior favela ea favela mais
complicada está à beira do meu tempo né
ea direita tinha a zona boêmia da cidade
aí eu convivi com a cia não chamava
naquela época as linhas da cidade
convive com seus clientes né
pessoas boas pessoas ruins e na favela
do marajá também convive com pessoas
boas com pessoas assim que intima karatê
nin e muitas pessoas tentaram a todo
momento e levar para um caminho do crime
para o caminho das coisas erradas e eu
me tornei o menino aterrorizante
o menino que sempre saía na parte da
tarde da sua casa depois das aulas para
aprontar na cidade de itabira para
realmente é não deixar as pessoas em paz
porque eu tinha montillo referência
familiar
eu não tinha é alguém ali que poderia
falar com o menino para fazer isso e
quando tinha ou quando alguma tinha
tentado fazer isso eu também não
respeitava elas mas eu tinha perdido
toda essa referência da estrutura que a
família e da importância da família na
vida de uma criança de uma doença
na escola é toda vez que eu participava
de uma atividade da escola ela da
actividade da barra do sul a atividade
juntar com aqueles meninos os mais
bagunceiros não era o centro de atenção
porque eu era realmente um tapetinho do
atentado era certa tensão e eu ganhei o
apelido muito carinhoso e eu vou falar
sobre esse apelido porque eu era
magrinho magni mesmo não gordinha hoje
mas eu tinha uma barriga eu te amo eu
era bom tudo eu era bem surdo e tinha um
cabeção magrinha todo mundo estava na
escola então de pt porque estava
passando aquele filme e esse filme
passava direto várias vezes na televisão
zinho pela parte da tarde e nos
intervalos dos amigos assim vão meter
vão meter o pt era uma situação na
escola eu me sentia um pouco reprimido a
forma de eu mostrar para as pessoas que
eu podia ser diferente ela fazendo coisa
errada dentro da escola
um certo dia eu andando pela escola a
diretora não gostava de mim
a bibliotecária muito menos porque o
castigo da escola era gente pro
biblioteca quando fazia coisa errada
engraçado né o castigo da escola
biblioteca então em obras e cara me dava
livros para poder ler é o mandarmos de
decorar poesia eu não gostava de poesia
de maneira nenhuma
poesia pra mim era uma coisa assim que
isso eu vou isso eu vou decorar essa
poesia fala muito obrigado é cara e não
importava com ela e obrigá la a decorar
poemas para fazer a apresentação da
escola quase um castigo então assim eu
comecei no primeiro no primeiro contato
com a literatura foi de uma forma muito
é da drástica porque a pessoa que tentou
incorporar isso passar pra mim não soube
passar da melhor forma possível sobre
passar de uma forma de obrigação que
tinha obrigação de incluir isso vão não
chegou a amc civilizar naquele período
com isso tinha um menino na escola esse
menino ele era diferente
nós na da turma da bagunça falar assim
essa menina ele fica sempre no cantinho
e ficava sempre com vários livros é
vários papéis falava sozinho mesmo
luquinha ea gente tinha também um
pouquinho de ciúmes
esse menino porque os diretores da
escola sempre nos jogos negócios em
número ímpar e um dia eu vi isso no
campo e eu como gosto de confusão chegar
perto dele faleceu em lei ou que estão
fazendo isso só o tempo sozinho como fim
a eu tô fazendo teatro
aí eu comecei a tirar daquela que fui lá
e peguei aquelas folhas de toda é que as
folhas a massey
só que eu faço isso direto com lanche de
menino mas eu aprontava muito só que
essas flores eu peguei e levei dentro da
mochila
também queremos ir pra casa e quando
chegava em casa nos momentos após a aula
depois de almoçar
eu sei pra rua pra furar pneu de carro
vai ter campanha na casa das pessoas era
se regerá fim dessa forma e só que essas
folhas ficou dentro da mochila e eu
tinha que é dar um jeito e joga fora
alguma coisa
teve um dia que eu deixei de ir até a
dona margarida dona margarida era dono
de uma mercearia no bairro título é dono
até hoje esse bairro é e ela sempre isso
eu sempre levava vazio pra ela novas
mesas novas cadeiras e ela me dava
depois um mega loja então eu gostava de
ir na gare da prefeita serviço pra ela
pra ganhar esse luxo é só esse dia não
fiz isso exige eu peguei esse material
do menino e fui foliares material era
uma peça teatral chamado o padre
assaltante joão bittencourt e nessa peça
conta a história de um padre que fazem
várias vezes a trapaças
nós chegamos apresentar o espetáculo
aqui neste palco é esse papo de fazer
diversos tratar a passo se chama muita
atenção com isso eu me aproximei muito
desse mínimo e comecei a virar um dos
melhores amigos dele e todo dia durante
o intervalo da escola não quis faltar à
escola
a gente ia fazer a leitura dessa peça
teatral e com isso nós construímos é
fizemos ou criamos na verdade o grupo
teatral arte vida
o grupo teatral arte vida ele chegou no
momento é muito importante e de
transformação assim na minha vida porque
primeiro eu parei de andar com diversas
pessoas que diziam que eram meus amigos
e essas pessoas dizem meus amigos também
não me aceitaram mais porque falava
assim também teatro a tirar tudo é coisa
de menino fazer então fim
então eu comecei até outras outros
momentos dentro da escola sindical
detritos também da escola
só que eu já estava apaixonado pelas
artes união tinha conseguido realmente
fazer uma mudança na minha vida o nome
de michel douglas conto que é trouxe pra
mim é uma possibilidade de eu entender
que existe um outro indo além do mundo
que eu vivi e que a literatura ela tem
essa capacidade de trazer pra gente
novas perspectivas tanto que nós criamos
nosso grupo de teatro é sendo menores
ninguém todo mundo do menor à mostra no
nosso grupo já tinha cnpj é prestar um
serviço para a fundação cultural
recebiam o banco central pelas usamos
nossos pais pra criar um grupo mas quem
seria esse grupo era gente mesmo assim
nós conseguimos mesmo sendo de menores
ter um grupo teatral e logo do grupo
trazia muita verdade pra gente porque é
fazer arte pra te vida com isso nós
começamos a apresentar pela cidade nas
escolas é começamos a ter um destaque
saiu na imprensa e que gostava muito
disso a empresa cada obrigado a pegar o
microfone eu quero aparecer era assim
também é nós começamos a apresentar e
com isso nós somos convidados é pra
entrar num grande programa preparatório
para o centenário do carlos drummond de
andrade
eu fui do mouzinho é o maior orgulho da
minha vida e um projeto também que mudou
muito é toda a minha história porque com
isso pois pude conhecer diversas cidades
é do nosso país né levando a obra do
monge ana e pude me apaixonar pela
literatura que eu também não tinha essa
vontade não tinha esse gosto pela
literatura é com o passar do tempo
neste momento está preparando para o
centenário
o secretário de cultura do estado ele
vem em itabira
o secretário de cultura do estado em
itabira e trouxe com ele toda a imprensa
era vários veículos de
é de televisão e rádio jornalista e nós
tivemos cinco minutos de fama e 58 foram
pra gente uma vez vim mágica porque na
hora em que passava estava indo
complementar ao do vinho outro vinho não
houve estupro estavam muito disso e
estou feliz perspectiva de uma vida
melhor é esse secretário ele era um cara
muito culto ele é um cara muito culto na
verdade ele falava muito bonito isso
precisava muito bem e eu curioso que sou
chegue até ele perder pois assim é o
senhor é de hoje
ele olhou pra mim e falou assim eu sou
de ouro preto uma cidade e artística e
cultural eu fiquei imaginando se ficar
deve ser da cidade do da alice no país
das maravilhas cidade maravilhosa pela
forma que ele me contou as histórias de
ouro preto passou seu tempo outro amigo
meu é mais velho do que eu foi morar em
ouro preto para ajudar 30
eu fui até um mercado da cidade de
itabira conversar com ele ele votou sim
eu estou estudando em ouro preto em
falou se o marcos lá em ouro preto
a gente tem trabalho demais porque a
actividade cultural acontece todos os
dias
então você vai ter como trabalhar lá eu
como luthier da satisfação muito em casa
eu só voltei eu peguei na mochila com
aquelas roupas e fui para o preto
chegando em ouro preto eu ainda não
tinha formado o ensino fundamental ou
ensino médio é então eu não podia fazer
a clínica e eu tava no fim eu estava no
fim do primeiro ano do segundo ano
então eu tenho que estudar em uma escola
secundária isso é então eu fiz uma prova
e passei no cefet e fui estudar os
efeitos fazer técnico em edificações
é o cefet hoje atual ea ufmg lá no set
eu percebi nos alunos ele eram
diferentes
eles eram politizados eles queriam
realmente fazer uma revolução no nosso
país e eu comecei a participar disso
também iria abalar cantando com eles as
bandeiras que eles defendiam e com isso
eu me tornei o presidente da umes ouro
preto na união da cidade municipal de
ouro preto onde que eu conhecia a fundo
a política porque a política em tavira
pra mim era
só pra eu poder ganhar brindes vinho
para chegar o vereador pediu dinheiro e
me dá pra fazer teatro era só pra isso
seria político nem imaginar que a
política era uma coisa grandiosa
apaixonei pela política e participei da
minha primeira eleição é municipal não
como candidato mas eu participei como um
ator importante estava discursando em
diversos lugares defendendo um projeto
que eu acreditava é definir esse projeto
nós ganhamos a eleição tanto no
executivo quanto o legislativo e quem
foi seu prefeito
nesse momento que não ganha eleição
aquele senhor que veio ver em itabira em
que era secretário de cultura não
conversei com ele então conexão existe a
todo momento
mesmo quando a gente não tá a gente não
se programa para fazer aquela colecção
as coisas acontecem na nossa vida quando
ele permite é eu pude perceber isso com
isso a equipa trabalhou durante vários
anos mais de 10 anos juntos é
desenvolver diversos projetos na área de
cidadania na área na área social e na
área cultural em ouro preto é e eu
sempre tinha uma coisa que me chamava
muita atenção porque a primeira com a
primeira vez que eu ganhei alguma coisa
na área cultural o meu irmão ele virou
pra mim é de uma forma bem lúdica e
falou assim olha eu tinha ganhado uma
uma bolsa pra fazer valendo uma das
melhores academias de itabira e virou
presença do senhor aqui em casa não tem
enviado para esse meu deus do céu eu
tenho apenas fazer arte é não só
trabalhar nisso dentro da minha própria
casa
você não vai deixar eu fazer angles e
com aquilo tudo então assim eu percebi
que tudo que estava acontecendo comigo
eu precisava vencer os obstáculos
eu precisava ser maior do que as
dificuldades que disputava acontecendo
na minha vida
com isso eu me formei em ouro preto ufop
é graduado em resposta graduação no
shopping é atingir a oportunidade de
contribuir muito com a gestão municipal
até mesmo lançando alguns livros ligados
à temática pública é ganhar um título de
cidadão honorário de ouro preto e
mergulha muito porque foi uma cidade que
realmente me abraçou e hoje eu estou de
volta em itabira
após 14
e eu venho itabira para fazer
provocações às provocações e só 1 diante
do das oportunidades que eu tive até
quando nós vamos tentar ficar é trazer
jando o manipulando as pessoas para uma
única forma de pensar
até quando a gente vai ficar é dizendo
que a pessoa tem que informar naquela
área robson tem que fazer aquilo que
aquilo que é mais rentável para ela até
quando a gente não vai acreditar que a
cultura é é apenas é entendimento para
muitos muitas pessoas acham que cultura
é apenas entretenimento ea cultura é
muito maior do que isso e até quando vai
ficar acreditando nessa verdade que não
é verdade
até quando nós vamos deixar o nosso
maior é patrimônio cultural que traz
toda a essência da cidade que nós temos
toda a nossa história que é o drumond
passar ea gente não usufruir da melhor
forma possível para o desenvolvimento
local para o desenvolvimento da cidade
de itabira então eu estou hoje aqui
inexistente para trazer essas
provocações para vocês é possível a
gente fazer a diferença é possível em se
tornar pessoas melhores
é possível ter uma cidade melhor e uma
cidade que vai ficar é desenvolver
diante de todas as suas potencialidades
só que a gente precisa primeiramente
acreditar em cada um de nós
obrigado